I don't know whether to whisper or to talk softly.
I don't know.
Hello, if you came from the last ASMR, then hi again.
I think I'm more nervous for this one, though.
I should have done it first.
I should have done the talking one first.
I think it's more difficult.
I'm too self-conscious, maybe.
I don't know.
I said that it would be positive affirmations, but what if I just talked from normal?
I'm just... instant.
Because I'm embarrassed.
Metal Gear Brain Rock ASMR.
Metal Gear, Metal Gear.
Metal Gear, Metal Gear, Metal Gear, Metal Gear, Metal Gear, Metal Gear, Metal Gear, Metal Gear, Metal Gear, Metal Gear, Metal Gear, Metal Gear, Metal Gear, Metal Gear, Metal Gear, Metal Gear, Metal Gear, Metal Gear, Metal Gear, Metal Gear, Metal Gear,
Metal Gear, Metal Gear, Metal Gear, Metal Gear, Metal Gear, Metal Gear, Metal Gear, Metal Gear, Metal Gear, Metal Gear, Metal Gear,
Metal When I look at these, I googled positive affirmations for a morning routine, and when I read these, they sound like things that would be said in severance.
I don't know why.
It just seems weird.
Hold on, I'm gonna... I'm gonna read some of these.
It was like a big ol' list, you know?
So it says like... Oh, here we go.
Every decision I make is supported by my whole and inarguable experience.
And then the other one is, I alone hold the truth of who I am.
It's so dramatic.
That's why I was like, these feel awkward to say.
So, I don't really know what to talk about.
But maybe I can still help you relax a little bit.
For those who are wondering if you watch the ASMR with no talking, you might have heard this sound.
It's actually a little purse that I got recently.
This is a purse.
Yeah, this is...
And it's really cute because it's got a little ghost on it.
And I picked it up earlier and I was like, whoa, this thing's crunchy.
I think people will like it.
But ASMR is kind of sexy though, no?
Now that I think about it.
If it's just like, oh, this
is...
Oh la la.
I used a...
A...
This one...
Is from a...
A hand towel I got from Kanazawa Zoo.
I wanna go back there.
Because they had...
A bunch of animals that...
Um...
That...
A lot of other zoos in Japan don't have.
Yeah.
Oh
no!
My video!
That was supposed to be long enough.
I wanna restart the stream.
It wasn't even 8K.
It's a 5K.
I
haven't been streaming for one hour.
Why?
The title did say there might be scuff.
You're so right.
I prepared...
I prepared for this moment.
So...
You can't say that.
You didn't expect it.
Okay.
Talk for...
How long this one go about for 30 minutes too since the other one did?
Or...
25?
30?
I don't know.
Sorry if you can hear my chair.
I feel like I'm moving around more.
With this...
I'm going to...
Spock your lines for positive affirmation.
This is...
This is my makeup brush.
Where did you hear the poka poka by the way?
I've never heard that onomatopoeia before.
Um...
My brain...
I just thought it might sound nice.
Sound like a heartbeat maybe?
I don't even know.
MGS3 on positive affirmation.
I don't know...
If I can say that.
Okay, let me try.
Let me try.
Okay, one second.
It's so creepy now.
I'm dead.
Creepy.
It's slowing because I'm tired.
I don't have a heartbeat.
I'm dead.
The proper ASMR might cost at least.
Oh, some people ask what I'm using.
I'm using the...
Three...
Three deal.
But it's not...
It was a couple hundred dollars.
I would not pay that much because...
I do not do...
I do not do ASMR very often, so...
I...
I would not get...
The very expensive one.
But I still wanted one that...
Sounds good.
Yeah, I think it's the...
The cool...
Cool...
One hundred.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think that's the one that is...
Really expensive.
Gifted memberships.
Thank you, guys.
Thanks.
Because...
But I guess today is...
A bit of an answer for myself.
I won't...
I won't do that again.
I'm sorry.
Creepy.
Can you even hear that?
Oh my gosh.
I just realized my noise gate...
Has been on this whole time.
Even in the last video.
I hope it sounded okay.
I don't know.
It sounded fine.
It sounded okay.
Was it okay?
I just turned it off.
I don't know, really.
Oh.
I can...
I can pretend to clean your ears.
Since I have...
I have the ear cleaner.
Does that sound even good?
You have so much ear wax.
Really deep in there.
Getting there nice and deep.
So much ear wax.
How can you even hear when I'm talking?
Um, um, um...
Okay.
I'm gonna have to get really deep.
Oh, positive affirmations.
Positive affirmations.
It's not about your ear wax.
Oh my gosh.
Um...
I'll just...
I'll change the title...
Of the stream.
Um...
I can say...
I
can...
Since it's Sunday...
Um...
You know, tomorrow you have to maybe go back.
I'm too embarrassed.
I can't do it.
I can't...
He's
getting mad at me for.
Why are you guys getting mad at me?
Oh, it's a public holiday.
Okay.
We'll just pretend, okay?
Pretend that it's...
Um...
Monday, of course.
That was not positive.
I was getting into it.
Okay.
Um...
Uh...
What are you reminding us?
I, I, I, I...
Um...
I...
I hope...
Um...
I, uh...
I hope you...
Um...
Have a good day at work tomorrow.
And...
Um...
I hope you...
Get lots of work done.
And...
Uh...
You're...
Doing a really...
Really good job.
So...
You know...
Um...
Make sure you don't work too hard too.
Because...
You...
Also need time to rest.
Okay?
So...
Oh...
But...
I can keep...
Cleaning your ears.
Because...
There's really just so much ear wax in here.
Okay.
I think I cleaned it all out.
What else can I tell you guys?
That will make you feel better.
What is it...
What is...
Something that you...
Wish to hear...
That will make you feel better.
No...
I can't bring pause because she will...
Be noisy.
Um...
I can say...
Hey...
You...
Listening...
Right now...
Sorry.
I think that was too loud.
Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry.
Do you want me to keep blowing in your ear?
I feel less nervous when I'm not talking.
Maybe I will...
Um...
Not do...
Talking ASMR anymore.
It's too much...
It's too much pressure.
Oh my gosh.
I was at the meet and greet yesterday.
And...
I don't know if you're listening.
But someone was like...
Oh...
I really loved Fauna's ASMR.
So...
I'm looking forward to your ASMR tomorrow.
And I was like...
Pressure...
Too much pressure.
I was like...
It won't be...
It won't be as good as Fauna's.
So...
Can you say...
Your Oshii won't graduate.
Oh my gosh, wait.
Your Audi...
Loves VTubers.
Enjoys eating oranges.
Your Audi...
Is an arsonist.
Is cringe...
And free.
Your Audi...
Lotions their whole body.
Out...
You guys know...
You guys know severance, no?
Like your innie and your outie.
O U D T I E.
Or out...
Or is it one T?
I don't know actually.
Really?
I don't know?
I thought it was a meme...
Where it was like your outie.
Okay, I'll explain.
So basically in severance...
It's like...
You...
Get a job at this place called...
Lumen Corporation, right?
And then...
When you work on the severance floor...
When you go to work...
You...
You switch to a different person basically.
And so...
Sometimes...
There will be...
So...
It's called the innie's and the outie's.
The innie...
Like the belly button.
So the innie's are the people that work...
On the severance floor.
And then the outie are the outside people.
And so...
Sometimes the innie's will go to therapy.
And there will be...
A lady there.
And she explains things...
She says things about...
About the outie.
So that they...
Feel a little bit more connected to them.
And so...
She'll say...
Really weird things.
Like...
Your outie...
Drives a sports car.
Or something like that.
You know?
And they're like...
Oh...
My outie is so cool!
So...
Yeah, this isn't spoilers.
Don't worry.
I wouldn't spoil.
Writing a script might help.
But I don't know.
Because I...
Still get nervous.
I think I'm nervous if I see you guys on screen.
Maybe...
I...
Maybe I...
You make us tokidoki too.
Are you tokidoki?
Is it because I sound so close?
Oh!
Sorry!
I accidentally dropped something.
I wonder why though...
Does that do anything?
Closer?
I can't because it's...
It's basically the base of my mic.
So...
It's not like I can...
Get closer.
Maybe I can find something that makes...
That sounds different.
It's like I'm cleaning...
I'm washing the dishes.
Just like a proper maid would.
Just
like a proper maid.
You...
Are...
Just know that...
You've already gotten...
This far.
And...
Also...
Because...
I'm haunting...
Believe in you.
Okay?
And...
Also...
Because...
I can't...
Possess you...
If...
You are dead.
So...
Make sure...
That you...
Take care of yourself.
Okay?
Positive affirmation.
That's two for two.
Yeah.
Yes.
You can beat Elden Ring.
And you can do it...
With minimum...
Deaths.
I believe.
Can I do it with ten...
Vicar?
What is that?
Uh...
Meme?
Yeah.
You can do it.
Level one.
No way.
Yeah.
You can do it.
One HP in a dream.
No summons.
One...
It's right here, baby.
Here's your motivation.
Get motivated.
Probably not, huh?
Don't use this for actual...
Relaxation.
I think you...
Should use this...
For...
Listening.
And then...
The actual ASMR...
That I did before...
For relaxing.
Okay?
O...
Oh, wait.
I think it's too loud, though.
I don't
know how to hum quietly.
Mm-hmm.
Mm...
Mm-hmm...
What's the thing that I can... instead that would not be so loud, I think?
It's too high!
I don't think this is relaxing at all.
I don't know.
The heartbeat earlier was nice.
No, I was too embarrassed.
I don't know how to hum.
That wouldn't be too loud.
So, I'm sorry.
I will end it in about a minute.
Isabelle's lullaby.
I'm sorry, I don't know why.
It's like Isabelle from Animal Crossing.
Hold on, let me try this.
Thank you guys for the ASMR.
Thank you for listening.
Sorry that... that... that it's awkward.
But maybe that is the... the minto way.
That it's awkward.
Probably.
So, I hope that, um, maybe the first one, the first ASMR was able to calm me down.
And that maybe this one could calm me down maybe a little bit.
Maybe.
Oops, sorry for sniffing in your ear.
Sorry for sniffing in your ear.
Sniff on.
Sniff more.
Wait.
Wait, my mic.
It does... it smells different.
It smells different on this side than it does on this side.
It smells like... it smells burnt.
I don't think that's a good thing.
weird.
But it doesn't smell bad.
It smells like ear wax.
It smells good.
It might be that it's your brain and it's overworking.
So you should go to sleep.
If it's time to go to sleep for you.
Or you should go to sleep later.
Or you're probably... if you re-listen to this.
I hope that you have good dreams.
And that you can get lots of rest.
And that when you wake up, you feel so refreshed.
Because you were like, wow.
Mito lured me to sleep.
Hakushu, hakushu.
Yeah.
So, thank you for listening.
And have a good rest of your night.
Hakushu.
I hope it doesn't happen.
Bye!